>> Russian president Vladimir
Putin might just be hoping that
they brutal Ukrainian winter
will succeed while his military
is been a dismal failure.
The Russian air offensive on
Ukraine's infrastructure has
widened, targeting the
electrical grid, now border
facilities under fire with
devastating effect Kyiv is
sitting with a prewar
population of 3 million.
80% of residents no longer have
access to running water.
That's according to the capital
mayor.
Notably, Ukraine's military
says that 45 of the 55 Russian
cruise missiles fired on Monday
were shot down.
Still meant at least ten hit
their mark.
Along with, Kyiv kharkiv in the,
east and zaporizhzhia in the
south, there have been reports
of heavy damage.
Appears to be no other reason
for the strikes, which of
course water shortages and
rolling power blackouts
nationwide are making the come
in winter the worst ever for
Ukrainians.
And Putin has warned that there
could still be worse to come.
>> After the terror attack
against the crimean bridge, you
said that in case there are
more, attacks Russia will
respond.
Can we call today's massive
strikes on Ukrainian territory
and search for recent events in
sebastopol?
>> It is so in part, but that
is not all we could've done.
>> As for the countries facing
food shortages, the price of
grain has risen after Putin
suspended but did not and
participation in a un brokered
export.
Deal the announcement came out
over the weekend, pressured
blame Ukraine for attacking
crimea, Russia claims movement
on the black sea grain corridor
is now suspended.
And using it would be risky.
Dozens of ships could be seen
using it on Monday.
Ukraine export deal is viewed
as a key to addressing the food
shortages in the number of
pictures around the.
World Ukraine says it remains
committed to the agreement even
if Russia back.
So >> I spoke with the united
nations secretary general
Antonio Gutierrez and informed
him about the level of
escalation due to Russian
actions.
Terror against Ukrainian energy
facilities and moreover,
against the background of
Russia's efforts to exacerbate
the global food crisis is clear
evidence that Russia will
continue to oppose itself for
the entire international
community.
>> Mr. Zelenskyy said Russia's
latest strikes on the
infrastructure will do little
to break the back of Ukrainian
resistance.
Air campaigns have never done
that.
CNN's Nick Robertson reports on
the capitol.
>> Life just got harder in Kyiv,
Monday morning, 80% of the
capitals water off.
Following a new barrage of
Russian airstrikes.
Spigots, not used since the war
began, a lifeline again.
But not unexpected.
>> Everyone who are in Kyiv
right now and they choose to
stay here, they are like ready
for this.
>> Will it make you leave the
city?
>> No, I will stay here.
I didn't leave.
Since the war began so I have
to do it now?
>> Despite the long lines in
some parts of the city,
patients aplenty.
For >> My friends in one hour,
maybe two hours, maybe three.
Maybe no water after 30 minutes,
but I will be back.
>> Scenes like this are
becoming increasingly normal
across Ukraine.
Government officials say that
there were ten different
regions targeted on Monday.
Eight teen different sites.
Among, them a hydroelectric
power plant, Ukraine's biggest
in zaporizhzhia.
Another power site in trick
cassie, central Ukraine.
Kharkiv subway in the.
East filled by strikes on the
vital infrastructure there.
And despite intercepts, 44
across the country, according
to the government, groups of
missiles getting through.
At least three according to
this witness near Kyiv's
hydroelectric power plant.
>> A missile flew over our
house.
I went to the balcony and solve
the second missile in a drone.
Both were flying in the
direction of the power plant.
It's so scary when you see it.
Three weeks of targeting
Ukraine's electricity network
is pushing the power grid
towards a tipping point.
No doubt more of this to come.
Nic Robertson, CNN Kyiv
Ukraine.
>> Retired U.S. Air force
colonel and military analyst
Cedric Leighton with us for the
latest developments on Ukraine.
Colonel, it's good to see.
>> Good to see you too John,
thank you for having me.
>> Always a pleasure sir.
What exactly does Putin mean
when he says that's not all we
could have done with regards to
the air strikes on civilian
infrastructure and what does he
hope to achieve.
Because these, aerosols these
air campaigns really work.
>> It's very interesting
because when you look at the
way air campaigns have been
conducted, you're exactly right
that these campaigns really
have the opposite effect of
what is intended.
They tend to stiffen the
resolve of the targeted
population.
And generally speaking unless
they're unsuccessful.
The air campaign is going to
fail if it is done in a way
where it is the only element of
power.
That is brought to bear and so
what Putin might be hinting at
here could be the use of some
other kind of weapon.
Some other kind of tactic.
Something that could perhaps in
his opinion changed the
calculus of the war.
So far we haven't seen him use
that.
Possibility here is a tactical
nuclear weapon.
I think that it is point time,
more of a bluff but something
we have to be concerned about.
>> What's interesting is that
the Ukrainian military says
that more than 50 Russian
cruise missiles fired Monday.
44 or destroyed by Ukrainian
air defense.
Still, those which reach their
mark have cost a huge amount of
damage.
Here's the Ukrainian president
now on efforts to restore
power.
>> As of, now restoration works
are ongoing in the regions
where there were hits by
Russian missiles.
Today we are doing everything
possible to restore the energy
and water supply.
We will restore.
>> I'm just curious, what is
the calculation here at this
point?
Is it going to last, longer
prudence to notice five
missiles or Ukraine's power
grid?
>> That's exactly right, we are
looking at Putin running out
the clock.
Who can run other supplies.
And I think that what we are
looking at is the possibility
at least that Russia will
expand its missiles.
Especially the type of cruise
missiles.
These are airlock cruise
missiles that they have used in
these particular tax.
They will lose.
They will run out of those more
quickly and the Ukrainians will
lose their will to fight.
And the Ukrainians will
certainly be able to restore
some of their power.
Some of their water before too
long.
I think they will be able to do
this fairly concerted fashion.
And it's going to be something
where they will beat the clock
in terms of whether or not
Putin will run this or not.
But it is certainly a sense of
where the Russians are going to
be spending a lot of money and
a lot of weapons.
In perhaps a futile effort to
force the Ukrainians.
>> After this, weekend which
Russia said targeted Russian
ships in crimea waters.
The Kremlin suspended the un
deal overseeing the safety of
cargo ships carrying grain
through the humanitarian
corridor.
Here is Putin explaining why he
did that.
>> >> Those crowds, sea and air
drones do partly in the
corridor through which the
green from Ukraine's exported,
they created risk for our
ships.
Which should provide security
for the grain exports.
Civil ships taking care of.
It made commitment to provide
security, but pardon me for the
expression, Ukraine hits those
ships.
Will be the one to blame.
>> We were the victim.
We've heard from a number of
people saying they just do not
buy that so from your point of
view how critical that
explanation?
>> Not credible at all, based
on what we know about the path
it took, was far from anything
resembling the path the grain
ships take from the course so
the Russian explanation does
not hold water in the.
And no other nation believes
that the explanations are not
credible at all.
So, that gets us to the
question of why.
Any clues as to why?
>> How, I think is using
anything that seems credible
and you can probably sell to
the rest of the Russian
population as far as, you know
his ability to conduct this for
and in terms of the ability
that he has to --
>> So, the Russian press will
spin this in a way that will
make Russia play the victim and
it will be credible for that
flood events unless of course